en el video anterior hablamos sobre cómo
cada átomo quiere tener ocho electrones
en su capa más externa Esta es la
configuración Más estable que puede
tener un electrón y dado esto que fue
determinado mediante observación podemos
imaginar qué es lo que va a suceder con
los diferentes grupos de la tabla
periódica un grupo de la tabla periódica
Es simplemente una columna de esta como
este grupo de aquí y de hecho voy a
comenzar con este grupo porque tiene un
nombre especial este grupo de aquí se
llama gases nobles y qué es lo común
cuando vemos un grupo en la tabla
periódica Qué es lo que tiene de común
los elementos que se encuentran en una
columna de la tabla periódica en el
video anterior vimos que cada elemento
de una columna tiene el mismo número de
electrones de valencia es decir tiene el
mismo número de electrones en su capa
más externa y encontramos cuáles eran
esta columna de aquí que es de los
metales alcalinos tiene un electrón en
su capa más externa y aquí les hice
notar que el hidrógeno no es
necesariamente considerado un metal
alcalino ya que comúnmente no se
encuentra en forma metálica y no quiere
ceder su electrón de valencia tanto como
otros metales cuando las personas hablan
de que un elemento tiene una
característica parecida a los metales en
realidad hablan de qué tanto les gusta
ceder un electrón y después hablaremos
sobre más características de los metales
en especial Cómo es que percibimos a los
metales con su brillo y conducción de
Electricidad y veremos esto como se
refleja en la tabla periódica pero
regresemos a lo que estábamos hablando
esta columna de aquí se conoce como
metales
alcalinoterreos lo escribimos
alcalinoterreos todos estos tienen dos
electrones en su capa más externa Y
recordemos que todos buscan tener ocho
electrones en esta capa externa estos
Quieren obtener los ocho electrones
agregando electrones a esta capa externa
y aquí Bueno les falta bastante este
tendría que agregar siete electrones
aquí tendrían que agregar seis
electrones Y bueno pues de dónde los van
a obtener ya que estos no van a querer
ceder sus electrones porque están muy
cercanos a los ocho que quieren así que
es mucho más fácil ceder electrones
cuando estamos del lado izquierdo de la
tabla periódica y de hecho cuando solo
se tiene uno para ceder especialmente en
los elementos que no son el hidrógeno
Cuando solo se puede ceder uno realmente
se quiere ceder ese electrón y es por
eso que estos elementos Aquí muy pocas
veces se encuentran en su estado
elemental Cuando digo estado elemental
me refiero a que el elemento se
encuentre puro es decir no hay nada más
que litio o no hay nada más que sodio o
no hay nada más que potasio de encontrar
estos es muy probable que se encuentren
ya reaccionando con algún otro elemento
probablemente con algo de este otro lado
de la tabla periódica ya que estos
quieren dar su electrón con muchas ganas
Y estos Quieren obtener un electrón
también con muchas ganas Así que es muy
probable que ocurra la reacción estos
siguen siendo reactivos pero no tanto
como los metales alcalinos y esto es
porque esos elementos están muy cercanos
a tener el número mágico de estabilidad
ocho y estos están un poquito más
alejados de ese estado ya que van a
requerir más energía a ceder dos
electrones de lo que este tiene para
ceder uno así que vimos que este grupo
tiene dos electrones en su capa más
externa y todos estos elementos de acá a
los que llamamos metales de transición
conforme se van agregando electrones van
a llenar todas las capas previas de la
subcapa d Así que su capa más externa va
a seguir teniendo dos electrones si este
es el cuarto periodo la capa exterior de
todos estos elementos tendrán 4 s2 Así
que estos elementos van a estar llenando
las capas anteriores del suborbital 3D o
de la subcapa 3D Estos son dos todos
estos tienen dos electrones de valencia
y todos estos al igual que que los
alcalinoterreos necesitan perder dos
electrones para entre comillas estar
contentos la forma en la que yo pienso
esto es que de cierta manera aunque se
basa en la realidad física todos estos
elementos tienen un numeroso conjunto de
electrones Así que aunque ellos pierdan
estos dos electrones por ejemplo
imaginamos el hierro que tiene dos
electrones de valencia aú cuando pierdan
estos electrones van a tener una gran
reserva de electrones en la subcapa d de
las capas anteriores si se pierden los
dos electrones de la capa 4S va a tener
todos los electrones de la capa 3D que
están en un estado de energí más alto
los cuales podrían reemplazar estos
electrones perdidos y aquí todo lo digo
entre comillas porque es la manera en la
que yo visualizo esto reemplazar entre
comillas y la razón por la que hago
énfasis en esto es porque los metales
están muy dispuestos a ceder sus
electrones estos elementos reaccionan y
dicen bueno saben qué toma mis
electrones Pero estos elementos de aquí
dicen con todos los electrones que tengo
en mi subcapa d puedo ceder estos
electrones porque la verdad tengo muchos
electrones tengo bastantes electrones en
reserva en mi capa d y lo que sucede con
los metales de transición y
especialmente con los metales estos son
los metales que no son solo un grupo son
todos estos de aquí lo que ocurre con
los metales es que tienen tantos
electones para dar no solo tienen estos
electrones extra sino que tienen llena
su subcapa d Así que pueden
especialmente si se encuentran en su
forma elemental y con eso me refiero a
que si tengo un bloque de galio puro el
galio no ha reaccionado con ningún otro
elemento tenemos solo un pedazo de galio
y cuando tenemos un pedazo de galio qué
es lo que va a pasar con estos enlaces
metálicos Pues en el caso del galio va a
decir yo tengo tres electrones en mi
capa más externa pero también tengo too
todos estos otros electrones en mi
suborbital d Así que lo voy a compartir
con los otros átomos de galio y creamos
un mar de átomos de galio o podemos
decir que tenemos un mar de electrones
que pertenecen al galio estos electrones
que se encuentran entre los átomos ya
que estos átomos están donando estos
electrones Así que el átomo real Aquí
voy a dibujar un átomo de galio galio
más que seguramente donó electrones y
aquí hay ro átomo de galio y este no es
un dibujo Exacto solo Les estoy dando la
idea de cómo funciona esto y es por eso
que los metales conducen la electricidad
muy bien ya que la electricidad es un
grupo de electrones que se está moviendo
y para tener electrones en movimiento
necesitamos tener muchos electrones que
se encuentren libres Así que los
elementos en esta área son muy buenos
conductores de hecho la plata es el
mejor conductor es el mejor conductor
del planeta y la razón por la que no se
usa esto en los cables y se usa el cobre
es porque el cobre es mucho más fácil de
encontrar que la plata sin embargo la
plata es mejor conductor como yo veo
esto es que cuando llenamos un orbital
este orbital se vuelve más estable todos
estos elementos han llenado su orbital d
mientras que estos otros elementos no
tienen totalmente lleno su orbital d y
tienen muchos electrones que son buenos
para la conducción pero bueno esa es mi
intuición no he hecho ningún experimento
para probar esto simplemente es para
darles una idea de por qué Estos son
buenos conductores Así que estos son los
metales de transición y estos son los
que se consideran los metales y la razón
por la que estos se consideran metales
de transición es porque están llenando
el bloque d y bueno los metales de
transición dan la impresión de que no
son tan buenos como los metales pero
cuando yo pienso en los metales el
hierro es el primer metal que me viene a
la mente también la plata el cobre el
oro también lo imagino como metal Así
que este término de metales de
transición no es respectivo ya que yo no
considero al aluminio como un mejor
metal que el hierro sin embargo en el
contexto de la química el aluminio es
más metal que el hierro Y estos
elementos de aquí voy a regresar con los
grupos de la tabla periódica aquí
tenemos tres electrones de valencia 4 5
6 7 todos estos elementos tienen tres
electrones en su capa más externa Y
pareciera que sigue siendo más fác para
ellos cederlos que obtener los que
faltan Pero quizá en ciertos casos
especialmente en el caso del Boro donde
pueda ganar cinco electrones que es algo
difícil de imaginar Ya que parece más
fácil ceder tres que ganar cinco y es
por eso que muchos de los entre comillas
metales oficiales se encuentran en esta
categoría y como podemos ver conforme
vamos hacia abajo en la tabla periódica
podemos tener metales que tienen cada
vez más electrones de valencia así que
por ejemplo el plomo sigue siendo un
metal aún cuando tiene cuatro electrones
de valencia Y esto es porque su átomo es
tan grande que su capa más externa se
encuentra muy lejos del núcleo Así que
esos electrones es mucho más fácil que
se cedan o que se pierdan Por ejemplo si
vemos el carbono sus electrones de
valencia se encuentran muy cercanos al
núcleo y es difícil de que lo ceda Así
que es más probable que el carbono gane
electrones a que los pierda mientras que
los electrones de valencia de estos
elementos de aquí abajo es están tan
alejados del núcleo que es mucho más
fácil que los pierdan a que ganen cuatro
electrones más y logren llegar a una
configuración electrónica como la del
xenón estos de aquí son los no metales y
es muy probable que ganen electrones y
esta categoría amarilla que les había
comentado que es muy reactiva
especialmente es muy reactiva con los
metales alcalinos de aquí esto se llaman
halógenos Y probablemente ustedes ya
hayan escuchado esta palabra antes
halógeno como como las lámparas de
halógeno y realmente no hay ningún error
en llamarlas lámparas de halógeno no fue
un nombre aleatorio y hablaremos en el
futuro sobre este tipo de lámparas de
halógeno y finalmente tenemos los gases
nobles lo interesante de estos gases
nobles es que tienen ocho electrones en
su capa más externa excepto el helio el
helio tiene dos la configuración
electrónica del helio es 1 s2 pero todos
estos de acá la configuración
electrónica de estees 1 s2 2
s2 2 p6 para el Neón así que tenemos
ocho electrones en su capa más externa
es un elemento feliz la capa más externa
del argón es 3 s2 3 p6 el criptón va a
tener en su capa más externa 3 s2 3 p6 y
también tendrá electrones en 3D ya que
llenó sus capas anteriores aquí pero
todos estos elementos tienen ocho
electrones en su capa más externa así
que Son elementos felices no tienen
ningún motivo para reaccionar como todos
los otros elementos y dicen bueno
ustedes tienen que reaccionar como
puedan en cambio nosotros somos felices
y no tenemos que quitar o ceder
electrones por eso es que estos
elementos son muy poco reactivos
prácticamente no reaccionan y hace mucho
tiempo cuando hacían los dirigibles
enormes como el hindenberg que es el
ejemplo más famoso usaban el hidrógeno
como gas y obviamente el hidrógeno es
una sustancia muy reactiva y es muy
combustible por eso es que explota muy
fácilmente y es por eso que ahora los
dirigibles o los que fabrican globos
para niños usan helio en lugar del
hidrógeno porque el helio es muy estable
es un gas noble que casi no reacciona y
es muy poco probable que explote De
cualquier manera Hemos llegado al final
de este video en el siguiente video
hablaremos acerca de tendencias en la
tabla
periódica y